it's wedding season
las vegas now's rocky thea shows us a
new local bridal salon
that's ready to unveil the current
wedding trends for anyone who's ready to
say yes to the dress
you can't get any more unique and
fabulous in this ostrich feather bolero
for your wedding i'm here at made in
white a brand new
bridal salon here in vegas alyssa you
are the owner of this beautiful shop
wedding season has changed post pandemic
it has so what's going on
yeah so generally that's later in the
year fall winter but that's not
happening right now
coveted brides are ready to get married
they've been penned up for a year
so this last month has just been amazing
i've had brides flocking to me ready for
dresses and ready to get married and you
just opened i just made it
a month ago may 1st so yeah hit the
ground running so let's talk wedding
trends because these models are just
absolutely so some of my favorite
wedding trends right now is this
beautiful blush color the billowy
sleeves
over here we have a cape which is a
really beautiful alternative to doing a
veil
i love this trend i love that and of
course we have the old hollywood the
classic here and then
i'm obsessed with the tats under the
wedding gown exactly
with the dress right right it's so
beautiful beautiful long sleeves at the
floral
details absolutely so looking at all of
these gorgeous models
how can one choose the perfect bright or
perfect wedding dress for themselves
yeah regarding body type and all the
different
exactly that's such a good question i
get that all the time with brides who
think that they have to stick to a
certain
a certain style based on their body but
that's just not true it really just
comes down to each and every person's
style
you put on a dress and you love it if
you feel confident you feel beautiful
you're going to look beautiful
absolutely and you just want to say yes
to the dress right we want that moment
so
do you have as a bridal shop owner do
you have a favorite say yes to the dress
moment
i do yeah i had a bride fly in from
florida all of her family
came in from utah and it was such a
magical experience because it was six
really independent really awesome rockin
women who
came down here for the experience um for
her to say yes and then they
drove back to utah for her sister who
had a baby all in the same day it was
amazing
yeah wow okay so they wouldn't have been
able to do it without you
so come on down to made in white brand
new open may 1st it is gorgeous in here
this is exactly where you will have the
wedding of your dreams you will yes
thank you so much alyssa